welcome back to Playstation grenade
thanks thanks for coming back I really
do appreciate it right in our last
episode we were in the main precinct of
the police station and we had to find
three medallions which we did with the
help of a brilliant young man named
Marvin bra know who is upstairs dying at
the moment I believe so maybe we'll see
him again soon let's take a home by the
way if you see that I am keeping all my
items which are discardable is because
there was a little secret in 1998 if you
kept all your discardable items so I'm
going to try and keep as much as I can
but I'll probably forget miss one thing
discard it and we'll miss the little
secret ending if it exists that is
anyway let's go down under the precinct
oh I like sleight now we are back in the
dark the sound design is so phenomenal
it's one of the best games for sound
design I've ever heard what's that noise
something above us it was your heart are
you fine with all this is it just me my
old man hearts nothing hidden around
here dog that dog locked
all right Leon put your back into it see
what you got come on bro you gotta hold
on get the Hat Superman that's what you
are dude
oh my word hi William
Oh
I'm okay
Jesus how do we fight this then bullet
God words won't work on this thing I
posted bullets won't work on this thing
right so back in 1998 those two types of
boss fight there was the one way you
actually fought and there was the time
based one way you just had to avoid them
for say two minutes and judging by the
items this is the fighting one come on
William you don't scare me
oh you do when there's a dead end four
bullets left
here you William have you ever played a
game called clock tower where the the
bad guy in that carries around a huge
pair of scissors and just drags it too
long and that's what this sounds like
right now
that will come in handy
thank you sir
is he mutating maybe that's his weakness
during mutation yeah well this would
faster how is he doing catch me I think
we can safely say this isn't a
time-based boss bike there's something
to shoot what do we do
maybe it's just a heads up muttering
each other seen spikes let's try them
below these canisters up down down okay
back to the drawing board
get off me will ya
come on kid hit your shorts
any ideas this is what I need live chat
right here's the plan we aim for the I
thing on his shoulder and hope that
there's a weakness that we can
are you doing William runaway oh bloody
hell that was close
[Music]
standing to deliver Stand and Deliver
this is where it goes down let's do this
big really Stiles is an angry little boy
here we go we doing fight me bro
okay we need to go in do I go in and
slice him up all right we need some
plain plastic come on come on
no that's not gonna blow up come on
let's do this please please please
please please please please please
please please please
yes no yes
I'm not sure top mutates I can't take
any more Oh
don't wake my friend he's dead tired
oh that's useful now oh my word I'm
tense up with us just breathe in through
the nose hey Liam
could use some heels 13 bullets despair
blast gone yeah but flaws out there can
make some bullets should we need heels
we're fine and on with our adventure
what's in here
I didn't
let's go look for a lever do it is all
that was satisfying
what's happening what's happening
you're doing well Leon the bridge bridge
is fully constructed and on with our
adventure that flashlight if it doesn't
run out of batteries
outlast has made me think that all the
time about batteries oh yes more pockets
and we'll have a cheeky save too onwards
and upwards
oh okay
car park the good old park hack dogs did
you hear it if I never move we'll be
fine
right so we need to open this barricade
so we will need a card okay can jabber a
knife in there damn need a key card
there's the dog
[Applause]
crazy [ __ ] excuse your knife man
Wow who is that
stay sharp heydo the girl of my dreams
lower it FBI sorry
thank you your help
surprised you made it this far
viii huh what's going on here
sorry that information is classified
where you going
classified do yourself a favor
stop asking questions and get the hell
out of here
so who believes that she is FBI I don't
hey I'm not done talking to you though
next time catch you up lady can we open
the boots trunk Hey
okay nothing to interact with out here
let's follow the wench
don't wake up do not wake up we go any
further let's just double check bullets
okay
get taken map noise prison prison and
parking garage
[Music]
who's in prison then gonna jump aren't
they they're all certainly gonna jump
out you stay back there Donna you stay
on the floor Steve Frank I will not have
that that was bloody scary corner Frank
me and you mano a mano was your friend
doing on the floor well these two these
two were in the act when they passed
away going down in a blaze of glory
anybody in this one okay so they're
locked so there be a central locking
system that we need to open hiya Vera
are you doing well hello hey real human
hello human
you've been here long long enough are we
the last ones alive no no there's a few
of us oh that's good news I guess yeah
that's of course iron sent you irons you
mean she finds is he still around
who cares hopefully he's somebody's
dinner by now what do you mean by that
he's the bastard that locked me in here
I'm sure he had a good reason he did I
was about to blow the whistle on his
dirty ass how done the same thing to him
I guess
I'll make it deal noise ease unlock this
cell and I'll give you this there's no
other way out of that parking garage
believe me take it off you know describe
it I can't do that I have to talk to the
chief you're too honest Leon we're both
prisoners in the station so either we
play nice and help each other out what's
coming come on don't be an [ __ ] you
need this look at that so I guess the
tyrants here mr. X who is that it's just
me so you can put that thing away
I don't even know what happened it just
happened so quick I told you to get out
of here wouldn't want to end up like Ben
would you not been know him he was an
informant had information of use to my
investigation so what he said was true
hey you can't keep walking away from me
I don't even know your name Dave Dave
Bautista I'm Leon Kennedy find a way out
before it's too late before it's too
late
then we'll talk
name's ADA names Adam
you missed the M lobe well I guess the
deal is on we need that parking permit
so how do we get in there it won't be as
simple as in Iceland world we've got a
tool I thought I was the only tool and
we need to put in some sort of circuit
breaker right clock tower circuit
breaker and I didn't read the first one
now we'll figure it out as we go along
he's going to open now it's red in here
which means it's something else to
happen no II like trickery
so that's locked up hi Frank we do mate
you're immune
you're immune
sorry Lovelace if you're here you are
not immune that's what happens with a
man with a knife see you sweet cheeks
and this woman should be launched - yes
don't wake up okay let's go to the other
side so we have a kennel we're going to
a kennel oh no that means more dogs
slow down slow Vence
the dogs are gonna crawl through those
slowly catchy monkey doors on trunks of
car seven five three nine okay so we
need to keep chip resume will be in here
so we examine well what's in the box
nothing okay bloody great oh this is the
target practice raccoon toys shoot
raccoon toys yes we've already started
doing that without being told
no-nobody wake up we'll all be happy
shotgun shells yes please thank you
kindly I like your hair look
so you just turn the electricity on we
need to find time but trying packets
that's it and here we go
okay so which car do you think it
belongs to - just try on the doors do
they have the car number on them two
three six
what am I missing let's just examine the
key all the keys broken hmm oh of course
of course and if how do you turn it
round turn around we'll press that yeah
where the hell was that sound over here
I think here we go we have got stock for
Matilda so it's gonna look like a little
submachine gun now I love you Matilda
but now you're going to be much much
bigger look at that beast
it's like Resident Evil 4 okay back to
the kennel
back to the camp
come on man up man up man up something
in that son of a [ __ ] literally is a
dog - son of a [ __ ] yeah stay in there
you don't want a piece of this I'm still
gonna stay on the side though - two or
three by the sound of it
[Music]
okay longer we blow them all my heart
goes oh yeah in the morgue a 39 year old
guy oh well this is gonna be fun no
bloody morgue what see what let's see
what's behind box number one nothing
behind door number two a thriving zombie
nope behind door number three nothing
there on door number four
it's our 39 year old Caucasian gentleman
who looks a bit peaky there's no teeth
oh the music the music is killing me
just take the key take the key take the
key take the key what did you come from
yeah tactics own on the docks on the
docks
okay we're all good we're all good oh my
heart we got this some cooking on gas
that noise from oh the two coppers must
have woken up inside the firing range
but where do we need to go or the
diamond doll because we have a diamond
Tina
the screams are so well done Oh like
like myself up into a corner on your own
love son of a [ __ ] ha ha I love that
voice all your friends here you down
Derek
sit down good boy
I'll leave you two lovebirds to it
I'm so lost oh this is new this is new
in the guardroom more bullets for us
then so we're looking for little circuit
breakers I believe
what about in the walls no there's wind
the clock tower
what is new I thought that was a mine
for a moment okay
new puzzle we need to get into those two
red lines okay so it's different orders
okay I'm okay okay Oh easy we have
electricity and we have music which
scares the crap
but what completely doctor please don't
be doctor please don't be notes they can
get in all gods all oh my butt
just drop dead - thank you thank you oh
this is gonna kill my heart is that it
just one another one who is dead and
back off [ __ ]
you don't want none of this herb in that
herb there's an herb
yep thank you kindly right so the
[ __ ] are out on they can crawl under
stuff
yeah I'll shoot my own door get back in
Altered one of them yeah don't come back
I'm gonna get out of it oh he's coming
around as long as there is the loads
right new tactic run and we run and we
come on a little bit left love it right
that's what we do that's what we're
doing Oh brick just keep running
oh my god oh my oh my oh my my we just
run no no I don't know where we going
lately just running around like a
headless chicken if this is too tense
never in a straight line never in a
straight line that's what the thing is
left and right left to right always
doing this through we go
I know hiding here oh my word my heart I
didn't stop saying that someone telling
how many times I talk about my house
shouldn't Frank you're scaring the crap
out of me oh no I've come back but I've
forgotten to actually pick up the thing
I need it okay we go back through the
doggies again life is good
oh that electricity didn't work over
here okay damn it we've got to go back
in there
we've got up the stairs Oh lovely
ready to run back through together with
our one shotgun shell okay we got this
that's right left to right stay calm
come on oh yes calm and collected Leon
oh oh you run round me Thank You boss
right I do believe we go through here
we've got electricity new section coming
back in the house for the precinct
whatever you'd like to call it oh and
now I'm a much better the Hat again I've
seen the Hat about six seven times now
and yes let's save definitely save I've
saved eight times already can you
believe that
eight times how many do you think I'll
have by the end I'll go for 25 oh well
here we go again shotgun ammo my
favorite ammo in the world three kills
coming up you're not coming in we are
saving this there is more than I
expected run away like the chicken I am
done miss
whoa I denied rapid-fire he's up again
already you keep eating there fella
I'm just going to do a little bit of
light electrical work and grab a knife
delicious always the copper David I
wonder he was called oh I miss him
already
right so we could go all the way back
through now you know we can't if we knew
the way to go let be even better
Oh rapid fire get used to this it could
be weighted right
oh yeah I remember where I am now yeah
that's why I use boards [ __ ]
I mean sorry sorry try my best not to
swear combine that with you and we get
some more ammo I think that's everything
now back to safety
ah life is good again are you doing
Marvin now looking - no I'm so sorry
babe sorry about your arm is Oldman
sorry to put your face off Marvin I'll
start this lieutenant you were my
favorite cop Marvin
goodbye my lover goodbye my friends
he was the best guy ever so let's stand
on his corpse Wow that's profound right
you know I'm gonna save and we will call
episode 2 the end there so 9 saves
hadn't stopped saving so often it's
worth it though
I don't want to miss anything ok so
we'll be back again tomorrow with more
Resident Evil 2 remake I don't know
about you but I'm absolutely loving this
it's been a pleasure I'm Adam from
PlayStation grenade
I'll see you next time